this has been building for years and
years and decades and decades and
actually
this transgender ideology comes
naturally from the left's
long-standing opinions on sex gender
biology and nature itself there's a
video that's gone
viral on tick tock i'm not a member of
tick tock myself but
you see these things go around the
internet and it's a guy who's wearing
very over the top sort of clownish
makeup you know red eyeshadow
and he's got big lipstick on and very
curly blonde hair
and one imagines he's a sort of some
form of
a transgender person but he's definitely
definitely a guy
and he's arguing that certain feminists
are really wrong and vile and
bone-headed
for believing that men cannot identify
as women and
while his argument doesn't make any
sense by the standard of reality
when you compare his argument to other
arguments the left makes
he's not totally wrong and before i get
some terfs up in my comment sections
being like women means adult human
female
first of all thank you second of all
y'all don't even know your feminist
history
second wave feminism was about relieving
women from their reproductive roles and
duties
it's regressive to reclaim
female as this like can
end all be all term for what womanhood
is like
literally know your history feminism was
not
about that feminism was about
alleviating
these gender roles and gender duties
based on reproductive capability it was
about getting rid of it
and that's why feminism belongs to us
queers and trans people now because
it begat us so [ __ ] off turfs
so that when he's referring to turfs by
the way he's referring to what's called
trans-exclusive
exclusionary radical feminists the
basically women who think that women are
an actual group of people and men can't
be women the thing is
this guy is almost entirely correct
about second wave feminism there's a
famous debate between betty friedan
at the very famous american feminist and
simone de bevoir the french feminist and
trumpet of jean-paul sartre in which
free dan says well women can do whatever
they want right and and
simone de vivoire says no we can't let
women stay home and raise a family
because if they have that choice they'll
take it and we need to force women
out into the working world so much of
second wave feminism was about
convincing women that there was no
special category of femininity that
actually if women wanted to matter and
have value
they needed to take on male roles and
responsibilities they had to
hold themselves up to male standards and
and that basically the only legitimate
virtues
were male virtues that's why they
a lot of these activists said no forget
about your kids forget about your family
you need to go out you need to go
work you need to go drinking you need to
treat sex the same way men treat sex
because the the idea here while
so many conservatives say you know third
wave feminism the new feminism is really
wrong but
second wave was okay first wave was
really good maybe the problem is just
feminism itself
maybe the problem is that the feminist
ideology
posits that there's no difference
between men and women
that men and women are maybe you know
they look a little different they got a
few different organs but there's no
significant difference
between men and women and what this guy
this gender ideologue is saying
is okay feminists i believe you there's
no difference between men and women so
then i
who am a man my biology everything about
me says i'm a man
maybe i can be a woman too maybe this
actually is
the logic of these leftist ideologies
coming to fruition and what a fruition
it is